[Music]
these spiny spheres are plant pollen as
seen under a microscope they're the
culprit behind most seasonal allergies
pollen can cause your immune system to
kick into overdrive because your body
sees the pollen as a harmful intruder
and as a result your body produces
histamines normally they promote healing
by increasing blood flow and
inflammation but they can lead to the
nasty symptoms that we associate with
allergies like sneezing runny noses and
watery eyes generally people who suffer
from allergies have it bad for several
weeks during certain plants growing
seasons but because of climate change
the level of pollen in the air is
getting much worse and that's bad news
whether you suffer from allergies or not
[Music]
in order to grow and produce pollen
plants need to generate energy through
photosynthesis that requires water
sunlight and a third necessary
ingredient carbon dioxide carbon dioxide
exists naturally in the atmosphere but
as we burn fossil fuels like coal and
power plants or gasoline in our cars
we're putting more and more co2 into the
air the more carbon dioxide there is in
the air the more plants grow and produce
pollen take a look at this graph these
bars are the level of carbon dioxide in
the atmosphere between 1996 and 2015 and
this line is the amount of pollen
produced per ragweed plant a common
source of allergens as carbon dioxide
increased the rattly produced more and
more pollen
and pollen is an important part of a
plant's reproductive cycle so more
pollen means more seeds which means more
plants producing more pollen the
following season but co2 is increasing
the level of pollen in another way as
well
carbon dioxide is a greenhouse gas and
it's called that because it traps the
sun's heat energy in the Earth's
atmosphere and is helping warm the
planet sort of like a greenhouse as the
climate warms there are more days above
freezing which means more time the
plants are active and producing pollen
this graph shows the number of days with
above freezing temperatures in the US
over the past hundred 20 years in the
past 50 years the u.s. growing season
has increased by over 10 days on average
and this isn't happening at the same
rate everywhere this map shows the
increase in pollen season for ragweed
between 1995 and 2015 while some places
like Texas didn't see much change in
their ragweed pollen season most places
especially those in the northern US and
southern Canada
saw pollen season increased by almost a
month and this isn't just happening in
North America overall most places around
the world are seeing longer growing
seasons and as a result more days with
pollen as well
pollen levels and allergies are only
going to get worse from here if carbon
emissions continue the way they are this
is the current production level of grass
pollen another common allergen source by
2060 that level is expected to double
and by twenty eighty five that amount
will have more than tripled while
allergies can be annoying for the one in
five Americans that suffer from them
they can usually be kept at bay with
over-the-counter drugs but in some
allergies can lead to severe reactions
like anaphylaxis where blood pressure
drops and airway start swelling shut and
pollen grains can wreak havoc on
people's lungs even if they don't suffer
from seasonal allergies in the u.s.
asthma attacks induced by pollen have
led to more than 20,000 emergency room
visits per year so if for no other
reason than to protect your sinuses it's
important to reduce the amount of co2
we're adding to the atmosphere it can
help curb how much we're warming the
planet and it can help slow the pollen
eclipse if your best strategy to avoid
seasonal allergies is to stay indoors
all spring then you might want a way to
stay connected and that couldn't be
easier to do from the safety of your
pollen free bunker hover makes it simple
to buy interesting domains with great
extensions like dot earth or not space
even if you don't need your own domain
you can set up a custom email address
like de nuit histamines can bite me net
and right now you can get 10% off of
your first purchase by going to hover
com forward slash box hover doesn't
impact our editorial but their support
makes videos like these possible